the idea that they're taxing to pay for
things that's something that people
should just put out of their heads the
point of taxes is to control inflation
that's it just to take money from people
they're gonna use they're gonna print up
the money that they that they you know
whatever they need to do whatever that
whatever uh program they want whatever
they need they just print it the fact
that the the federal government collects
taxes means that the dollar has a value
because you have to get dollars to pay
those taxes they use taxes and interest
rates control to control inflation there
is nothing backing it the only value
that comes from your dollar is
is from the demand for taxes so the we
have to get away or people should try to
get away from the idea that we are using
taxes to pay for projects and the the
argument against mmt is it gives the
government
unlimited authority to print money and
do whatever they want with finances